non-minimalists
what should i do with dead batteries
yeah so i read this question
and my first thought was like well you
go to you know whatever electronics shop
you go to and they typically have
battery recycling stations yes but then
you were talking about
how
you have found something new to do
and and
and you said you're trepidatious about
it so yeah what do we do with our debt
batteries yeah that's a it's a good
question it's a nuanced question thank
you sarah now first off i tell you what
i do currently there's a place because
right now target here doesn't take them
anymore best buy doesn't take them
anymore oh wow we used to uh give them
to wework they don't take them anymore
either and so there's a place at ucla
that's open one day a week that will
take old batteries so you have to like
plan around that drive out to westwood
etc but this is from the u.s forest
service this is uh fs.fed.us
and the question is what should i do
with dead batteries
batteries come in several different
types proper disposal depends on the
type of battery you have so we start
with um ordinary batteries versus
universal waste batteries those are the
two main categories here okay so
ordinary batteries regular alkaline
manganese and carbon zinc batteries are
not considered hazardous waste and can
be disposed of with ordinary trash
so is this like uh
like a duracell battery is that double a
batteries that are in that clock
alkaline okay yeah okay and so
according to the u.s forest service
you can throw those in the trash
personally i'm not there yet yeah but
according to because i okay i can go to
ucla or whatever huge inconvenience to
do that
but now that we have emma and mallory
maybe it'll be much easier for us to get
rid of our batteries
yeah we just give ours the emma mallory
yeah that's what you all can do too
other common single use or rechargeable
batteries such as lithium and button
batteries are recyclable but access to
recycling may not be available in all
locations
so i mean you think most
medium medium-sized or small cities
aren't going to have access to recycling
those types of batteries right yeah you
may be able to take these batteries to a
household hazardous waste collection
event or drop off location sponsored by
your county city waste disposal district
or health department and then we move on
to universal waste batteries these are
the nickel cadmium batteries and small
sealed lead acid ssla rechargeable
batteries are considered quote universal
waste these batteries are commonly
encountered in emergency lighting exit
signs security systems and alarms
they're expensive to purchase
but they are rechargeable overall
they may save the use of hundreds of
disposal batteries disposable batteries
over their lifetime providing good life
cycle cost effectiveness all universal
waste batteries produced since 1997 must
include the following wording on their
labels battery must be recycled or
battery must be recycled or disposed of
properly you can search for local
rechargeable battery recycling
facilities by zip code at this website
earth911
so the website we'll put a link to this
article in the show this is earth911.com
refer to the everyday hazard
users guide for more information about
nickel cadium and ssla battery disposal
and universal waste
and so
basically your everyday
batteries the alkaline batteries that
most people use you can just
theoretically we can toss them
the other batteries they need to be
recycled there's a website where you can
search here in your area to find the
best place to dispose of those properly
man it is uh
it's not easy like doing the responsible
thing you know or the i don't know what
you want to call it whatever thing it is
like the thing that's good for the
environment i mean that's why we are
where we're at is because we don't
we take the easy route we don't do the
hard work it's not it's not easy to not
harm
is maybe the way that i think about it
yeah because we don't realize the harm
that we're doing quite often
with uh you know if you were to just
take one of these universal waste
batteries the nickel cadmium batteries
and you throw it in the trash can
and that goes to a waste site and all of
a sudden you know that that is
contaminating the environment oh it's
just one thing yeah but if everyone does
that one thing it's such a problem
yesterday i was walking uh with ella we
were walking around the block and she
has always tempted to pick flowers off
of other people's flower bushes
and
there's like this bush there beautiful
bush with all these purple flowers maybe
a hundred flowers on it 50 flowers yeah
and and she pulls one off of there and
her mom goes hey you know we told you
400 times not to do that right and she's
like but it's just one flower
and then
bex goes yeah but you know if there's 50
flowers there and 50 people walk by and
do that
how many would be left and the look on
her face like oh yeah
it's not just about me did you enjoy
this video if so you can listen to full
episodes of the minimalist private
podcast available exclusively on patreon
visit patreon.com
the minimalists today your support keeps
our podcast and youtube channel 100
percent advertisement free